-Recently, there has been a
disturbing trend of white women
calling the cops on black people
who were just
going about their business.
First, there was a woman
dubbed "Barbecue Becky"
who called the cops
on black people
barbecuing in a public park.
And this weekend,
a woman dubbed "Permit Patty"
called the police on
an 8-year-old black girl
for selling water to raise money
for a trip to Disneyland.
Here with more thoughts on
white women calling the police
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
as '80s pop star Rockwell.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ I'm just an average man
with an average life ♪♪
♪♪ But white women lately,
they fill me up with strife ♪♪
♪♪ All I want
is to be left alone ♪♪
♪♪ Then I see one on the phone ♪♪
♪♪ And that makes me feel like
I'm in the Twilight Zone ♪♪
♪♪ And I always feel like
white women watching me ♪♪
♪♪ And I got no privacy,
oh-oh-oh-oh ♪♪
♪♪ I always feel like
white women watching me ♪♪
♪♪ Gonna call the cops on me ♪♪
♪♪ When I'm at a barbecue,
even in a public place ♪♪
♪♪ I break into a sweat when
Becky looks me in the face ♪♪
♪♪ She says she's on the phone,
will her staring ever stop? ♪♪
♪♪ Does she want to do me in, or
does she want my pork chops? ♪♪
♪♪ When I'm selling water
for a trip to Disneyland ♪♪
♪♪ Patty says I need a permit ♪♪
♪♪ Unlike a white kid's
lemonade stand ♪♪
♪♪ People say I'm crazy,
a little touched in the brain ♪♪
♪♪ But if you ask me, it's these
white women who are insane ♪♪
♪♪ Because I always feels like
white women watching me ♪♪
♪♪ And I got no privacy,
oh-oh-oh-oh ♪♪
♪♪ I always feel like
white women watching me ♪♪
♪♪ And I got no privacy,
oh-oh-oh-oh ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give it up for Amber
Rockwell Ruffin, everybody!